well I'm Raquel Ramirez from Venezuela
and I'm visiting my daughter who lives
in Paderborn let's explore the city
together
they drag me behind me is the Cathedral
of Potter Blanca come on it's full of
surprises
the light in this church has always
impressed me ever since the first time I
came to Paderborn that's where this
meditative atmosphere comes from
wait now we're in the cemetery in one
seventh day do what followed me look up
here please these are the famous three
rabbits
here you see three years but they really
have six funny isn't it I don't
understand why but I've heard that it's
a symbol of the Holy Trinity say humming
if you go where you know this is the
patter born market who buy the world
navigate it's a part of one bratwurst
very good ain't it
what I don't understand is that people
can eat outside in the cold like this
it's hard because your fingers freeze it
no way no oh I don't know he now we're
going to take a look at the do saison
Museum even though it's dedicated to
religious art at the moment you can see
an exhibition about garbage let's go in
what's that ooh
we cackle
though all of the people are made of
rubbish from cans and plastic what I'm
fascinated by is that you could have an
exhibition like this in our religious
museum capacity yeah what would you
think of all this st. Joseph if you were
alive and knew you were standing in the
midst of so much garbage I can't imagine
Akito Inco this is the source of the
Powder River
it's how the city got its name what are
you doing what are you doing why it
makes Springs look bubbles let's get it
Wow well how incredible bubbles really
do come up when you jump see to salt us
Biggi think we'll see these sculptures
there Paderborn washerwoman this is the
way they washed their clothes in the
Potter 60 years ago
syndulla a river is very important it
flows through town gives it its name
what is it's the city's lifeblood I'm
going to say goodbye from here come to
paderborn it's worth it I'll certainly
come again